[Music]
go all right hey hey folks here we are
we oh [__] wait let me change shirts oh
jeez it's too late the Magic's ruined
they know it now son of a [__] all
right well we got we got old Russell
here yeah yeah and Winnie Winnie who's
looking uh particularly aroused by you
changing your shirt yeah who isn't
tongues out yeah what are you doing in
the uh across the pond uh I'm doing some
so uh yeah I'm doing a a uh an East
Coast tour um which I'm really excited
about so we're kind of I'm going to a
place called Durham tomorrow I've never
even heard of dur Durham Durham North
Carolina durh so how am I how was I
pronouncing that different is that is
that what we do when we come to yeah I
was going but Durham it's Durham durh
Durham Durham yeah yeah it's Durham in
the UK and it's weirdly a very kind of
Posh place in the UK right up the north
so it's on so it's in it's not what it
is here yeah right but it's in a very
skanky area in the in the north of
England and yet it's quite sort of Posh
no it's dur Durham's a cool I mean it
North Carolina is pretty cool I mean the
big cities there North Carolina's got
like you know you know Durham and then
you know Ry Durham and then you got uh
you know the cool like they have like
artsy cities like Wilmington or
Asheville they got smaller it's yeah
it's a cool State nice I've been been to
North Carolina once me and my mom did TV
show like a travel show and we had to do
this kind of Speedway thing where I was
in a car smashing into other cars in
front of like 5,000 people in this kind
of weird we call that the Tiger Woods it
was [__] incredible but it was all
like like proper weird like Trump Flags
Confederate flags it was [__]
peculiar yeah my mom was there
commentating cheering me on but
desperately you did a show with your mom
yeah yeah so it's kind of um we did a
travel show years ago um when we
traveled around around America what how
was that working with your mom so
closely it was great my mom's really
funny but the the the bad thing about it
is that after a while you become like
work colleagues yeah and then you're
kind of like that horrible moment you
turn to your mom like like that and you
kind of raise it a bit and you realize
she's just your mother who's just
bewildered because you're in the middle
of India and you're like come on let's
try and make this a bit funnier oh
that's so it was a bit it it kind of it
was great and then at the end it just
got a bit we were sort of Sly resentful
of each other so we had to stop so we
could become mother and son again rather
than do you know what I mean like
colleagues it was weird with my mom I
[__] about everything I'm like oh this
gig suck but now she's with you so she's
like yeah I'm here I get it yeah but
pissed too and she realized what it
meant to not be sad to be away from home
oh because you're on the road you're
enjoying yourself and everyone oh you
must want to get home and you're like
not really yeah yeah do you know what I
mean that's what all standups you love
doing the road I love it don't you I do
I get to a point where I'm burnt out but
then I come back and I'm like I missed
the road yeah I'm always grateful to
return but I do love I feel like that's
the only way to improve your act is to
you know hit the road hog oh hell yeah
but you just see just so many different
parts of the world as well you know it's
like we were talking the other day about
like gigging in Lisbon you learn so much
about standup seeing if you can make
your act work in Portugal yeah you know
and they're listen to you in their
language right and stuff works stuff
dies and you s of see how strange your
culture is compared to theirs and well I
think you'll find the East Coast cuz
when I got to Dublin and London I was
like all right I'm home CU you know
Lisbon was it felt like a barrier and
like Germany was a little barrier but
those two or Manchester or Birmingham
that was like all right I can just do my
ACT yeah I can be myself I don't have to
like try to adapt a little bit Yeah
Holland is the big one for me if you
kicked in Holland oh I did Amsterdam
yeah [__] me because they don't laugh
it's just like that was amusing hear in
my teeth for like an hour they just
smile at you they smile and then at the
end they go ballistic and you realize
the gig's gone fine but why why is it
because they're concentrating so hard
they speak five languages and you're
there just churning out language and you
think you're speaking at a normal Pace
but words like nicking a cow doesn't
mean stealing a cow it means cutting a
cow so gone on different variations
right I've never heard I mean I don't
know Nicki n either exact that's what I
mean so I was talking about this in
Denmark and I just said the phrase one
of my mates got pissed and nicked a
nicked a cow which in America would mean
my mate got angry and stole a cow but it
meant he got drunk and he nicked a cow
how do you steal a cow well exactly that
was the whole point of it he was
bullshitting but but the point is they
went on a different Journey do you know
what I mean and it's just you sort of
realize the importance of words yeah
everywhere do you know what I mean it's
the whole business but I noticed the
prettier don't take this the wrong way
the prettier the city the worst the
crowd like Lisbon is beautiful it's like
breathtaking these these cities with the
the Alleyways and the cobblestones but
the crowds were kind of they were a
little felt distant and then Amsterdam
is so cool looking and so pretty but the
crowds were a little clappy interesting
Miami hot women big fake butts big boobs
bad oh really yeah and New York complete
[__] oh good crowds well yeah it's a
pretty city but you got the guy J is it
pretty city is New York the skyline's
beautiful when you're in a rugged way I
don't it stinks of weed and piss well
there you go and there's I know but that
keeps us humble the actual architecture
is good it's just that's what you think
you they're pumping in the smell just
okay it keeps us it keeps us human right
right exactly there is I've I've been on
the subway twice and I've seen three ass
TOs and one bloke jacking off and really
none of them met us no no no no but they
were just so like this guy was just
jacking off in a real ho
hum like that and it's like surely if
you're beating off in public there
should be a bit of excitement to it and
and nobody was everyone was just like
another day another guy jacking off here
it's like directions you take a left of
the JK off guy you know it's pretty
common what if he's not there he'll be
there yeah he's on the D TR yeah every
time my mom this is when I learned a lot
by my mom she came here to come visit me
and I was like take the F to meet me and
we went went out to dinner and there's a
guy jerking it and she didn't bring it
up till like two hours into the night
she's I miss your
father yeah but I was like hey Mom's fun
she doesn't like most women Pearl
grabbing oh my mom was like oh yeah
there was a guy jerking it you know my
mom did that as well how funny that in a
flat that I used to live in made ofil
there was a guy who who was I'm probably
thinking about this cuz of Winnie but he
was getting jacked off by his girlfriend
and he was holding a dog on a lead next
to a tree and my mom went and I didn't
know this was the scene that my mom was
beckoning me towards but she was like
look out the window oh like so my mom
kind of took me to this kind of live
only fans yeah you know but she just
didn't care she's like look at that so
he's he's getting jerked off and the
dog's on a walk yeah and the dog was
yeah exactly that's a bad walk for the
dog terrible walk but there's so much
going on the dog and the dog looked like
this had happened before the dog wasn't
looking at him as if to go a come on
Jeff right do you know what I mean
Winnie it was that sense of yeah that's
how he lost the eye got hit with it
ruined him her sorry I want to misgender
what do we got here these are some
treats she's been good you got to give
her L some trees what what is that it's
like beef jerky for dogs that that
looked like weed from here I was just
like oh it's got some weed in it that
doesn't look like she's going to be
spinning yeah yeah by the way I got
turned down for life insurance cuz I
smoke weed I didn't know that was a
thing why you tell them I was trying to
be honest well weed's healthy now
glaucoma and arthritis like none of
those yeah we doing it during you
weren't you didn't roll up with a joint
well I'm not a weed guy I need some life
insurance that will stop him pretty
quick but I'm like just tapping heroin
into your own i e it now well I I was
just like hey I I'll an edible every now
and they go to bed I don't even like
weed only to go to bed and they were
like ooh I didn't know that and then
they you know marked some stuff off so
hang on a minute so you so you now have
no life insurance because of that yes
but I'm like does Snoop Dogg not have
life insurance or Willie Nelson what are
we doing here probably not I guess not I
guess they're rich enough but I willly
Nelson needs it that guy's going to live
forever yeah but why did you say I just
said I took an edible a couple times to
go to bed I don't even do it that much
anymore and they're like oh really what
I don't understand why that disqual I
didn't think it would I was trying to be
honest yeah I don't even do it anymore I
just it was a phase can you and you
can't bring them back no once you're
done you're done it's like a elimination
from the island I'm out unless you you
come back and you go listen I was under
some pretty heavy
drugs I was on acid that day which I no
longer take and I likeed I don't I don't
take Ed is life insurance that's cuz
you're married now is that why you're
getting that yeah and you get a little
text something or other so I was like
all right I'll try to beat the like they
always doing the life insurance thing in
like the movie where you kill a spouse
oh it's always you always get like the
deal and you're just like it was up to
800,000 and then it's like and he he was
he dropped dead yeah you know that's
like the [__] life insurance thing
that's true and they always say the
number every time like oh yeah they were
going on grade then they got married and
then she found out you get 38 Grand that
was Double Indemnity if you if you fall
off a train you get like an extra they
double it so it have to be like an extra
whatever oh yeah yeah cuz if it was like
a peculiar death it would have a claw in
it so it would be an even even more
amount of money right we have we have to
do it in the UK if you buy a house you
have to have kind of life insurance why
is that I don't know I guess so that
they can retrieve it if something goes
bad if you so you can your partner can
then pay the mortgage I guess I love the
idea of Epstein like I'm trying to buy
this
island and then having to fill out the
forms thank you you can that's for sale
that was clearly the worst bit of his
life admin I hate admin he's he's paying
for life insurance how could it get any
worse than thisly but imagine that a
documentary that just focuses on all the
[__] yeah egg shaped penis too that's
the rumor he's not right egg shaped
Epstein yeah picture that yeah weird egg
look it up they might have a photo you
know what's weird is uh galan's vagina
was shaped like a beater so it's kind of
perfect for each other woo beater what
we having to look for buzzer beer we're
looking for I'm okay thank you though
yeah you're not a Diet Coke guy no we
got we got Russell 19 Diet Cokes egg
you're a Diet Coke guy do you coffee and
Diet Coke no it's that's a weird combo
yeah it's silly isn't it it's just I'm
really struggling with J to be honest
it's the first time I've ever spoke
about my caffeine needs was also looking
at egg shaped
penises this doesn't help us it's just a
bunch of eggs in the shape of a dick
yeah I mean that one on the right that
is do we have to blur that or can we
show it I don't know show that's more of
a that looks like an air that's been
ripped off in a traffic accident doesn't
it you know what I mean that's a high
impact it looks like a penis on one of
those like science experiment things you
oh yeah yeah egg sh that's kind of fun
apparently Harvey had a wacky dick too
yeah I heard that it was that it was all
like didn't they have holes in or
something like that and he s holes yeah
that's what I had one hole no no no it
had like many holes many holes so we had
to hold it like a
recorder like apparently like yeah yeah
when he pissed but again it's as soon as
you hear twinkle twinkle little star
well but as soon as you hear and my
friend Sam told me that rumor and I
can't shake it but yeah I like
caffeine there's a pattern here with the
the weird dicks and even Hitler had one
ball so and a micro penis and a micro so
male genitalia it'll dictate your whole
personality so from the TV naked
attraction you could surmise whether or
not people are insane have you seen that
show I haven't seen it now apparently
it's just come over here and basically
it's where British people get it's on
HBO which you know really shows that HBO
is struggling you this this is this is a
network that made the wire and now
you've imported a show where English
people are naked basically a screen goes
up and then you see their junk or their
vagina and the uh lady or the man just
goes over and sort of looks at them and
judges them whoa and it's like blind
date but backwards completely and then
there's F and then one person gets voted
off and then eventually they see the the
person ho and then they go on a date
fully clothed wa and that's now what is
what is the purpose of this it's we're
starting ENT value no but I mean like
what is their their version of like
what's their pitch for I guess their
pitch is probably some horeshit about
you know everyone tells a lie but the
skin does not you know something like
that and it's like you know this is the
truth but you basically just have weird
English people kind of glaring at
nuts and the kind of host is going so
you do you like a full Bush or do you
like it Trimm back Darren you know and
he's I not M really in between you know
what I mean apparently it's kind of it's
we've had this show for like a decade
but it's just come over to America I
can't wait and I read a story that you
were kind of understandably horrified
yeah that this is what we've been doing
for 10 years but um man what is I was
watching this Roman Empire docu drama on
Netflix and it's it's pretty cool it's
pretty fun but it's also hilarious that
every actor is gorgeous like the women
the women that like ciglar is [__]
it's you're like all right they have
giant f fake tits and uh and a shaved
vagina which I'm like I don't think I
don't think they were waxing in ancient
Rome the [__] Stamp is unbelievable
they had a bush in the 80s I don't think
they were [__] you know clean in the
in ancient Rome but it's pretty fun I
mean they're just it's like Caesar Kula
well you can't go wrong cuz it's like
Game of Thrones it's action it's tits
and it's drama and yeah and history and
Dragons so you put enough of everything
in there and somebody will watch dragons
have really stood the test of time
haven't they yes they've kind of always
been around things have come and gone
but the dragon has remained pretty
that's true pretty strong and it's
always fascinated me as to why but it's
kind of it's like some countries have a
dragon on their flag yes yes the Welsh
it's a dragon really yeah man it's a big
red dragon China does the uh the dragon
parade thing every year yeah people love
dragons and dragon Queens but yeah a lot
of dragon Dragon Roll yes kodo yeah
Dragon Queen sounds like something you
know a very right-wing person would do
at school
[Laughter]
right right yeah everybody loves a
dragon something the fell off that's
kodo Dragon a full deer a oh well don't
pull that up because we won't talk we'll
just be enjoying it see this is the just
swallows that thing oh
man it's like the porn star of the
animal kingdom I mean that's deep throat
yeah and then it and so you mentioned by
the way you mentioned you came you go
that Dog Day Afternoon it's just a
sweaty picture of Pino are you a film
guy yeah so funny enough I my friend Joe
maio who is a uh he did the sound on the
TV show that I did in America he said
the other day that Dog Day Afternoon is
the the best film ever made I would say
it's in my top 10 top five but for me I
mean personally it just it's it's New
York it's uh it's got the the Thrills of
a of a heist like a bank robbery movie
but then it's got drama it's funny trans
it's got the draag it's got the trans
thing but they handle it in such a
progressive way it's pretty I I think
it's one of the best movies ever made
for me I saw for the first time two days
ago it's incredible it's incredible but
and and the it's so tense and the fact
that they're sweating the there's more
sweat as it goes on yeah John Cazale is
in four movies and they were all five
and they're all nominated for best
picture we got the conversation
Godfather one and two the Deer Hunter
and uh dog day dog day so you're in five
mov
in your dating Merl stre you can't be on
a hotter streak yes if you die in love
with Merl stre in a relation you won wow
she often said that yeah that was her
thing
yeah you died tonight you've won yeah on
his deathbed congratulations you uh you
really crushed just as he's yeah just as
he's choking out you made it I mean say
hey to God and then you see God and it's
M Street that movie is so it's so good
man there's another one that salaku and
I love that's like part of that kind of
vibe of 70s flicks the original taking
of pelum 123 oh yeah that's a great film
that's another one I think you know what
are your you're a movie guy what are
your like favorites oh God that's a
tough question isn't it that like I
think the the film I've watched the most
is probably the Royal Tenon bombs movie
that's a great I just think like cuz I
got two nephews at the minute and they
look like they need a bit of Royal you
know what I mean like me and my brother
often sort of say that two kids that
need to go to a dog fight just they just
need a bit of rough and tumble they kind
of need I I love that film great movie
that was when Wes Anderson was really
cooking cuz no offense but asteroid City
I it's like he's jerking off I thought
that was oh yeah I didn't see that one
there's a new one with Benedict
Cumberbatch as well where someone needs
to sort of just shake him a bit mate
come on it looks beautiful you've got to
tell stories well they always they
always look beautiful but it for me
Rushmore is probably my favorite one but
I love Royal Tenon bombs ten bombs is
good um Grand Budapest Hotel is great
that was incredible
fun film but that's where he's I feel
like he's starting to go too wesy but
it's got It's it's got heart without
being annoying it's still good that's a
very hard line to walk you there's some
beautiful lines in it as well like the
the bit when they kind of stab each
other and he goes I suppose you'd call
that a school draw like there's some
really forgive me zero my dear dear
friend there's some beautiful heartfelt
moments what makes it extra interesting
is that William defo in that film is a
absolute dead ringer for my dad no way
yeah so
and he has a real Menace in that film
and my dad's Quite A peculiar bloke so
when he throws the cat out of the window
it that isn't inconceivable that that's
something my dad could do I've seen my
dad kill a rabbit with a spade oh jeez
but the dog the rabbit had mixim mosis
but but we didn't know that yeah there
was no explanation he just picked up the
Spain and went to it damn yeah uh does
your dad also have a huge dong cuz
Willam defo his dong is so big that they
have to edit like CGI his package to
look smaller or else it be distracting I
don't think that happen isn't he a tiny
guy that W that doesn't stop is is it
proportional I mean proportionately it's
huge I mean but is it just I think it's
huge huge interesting well do you ever
see him in that movie To Live and Die in
LA no that's it's a it's William freakin
who did like Exorcist and French
Connection it's a fun it's an
off-the-wall cop crazy shoot him up
William Peterson badass uh movie and
sorry is that him you sure that's him
yeah how much work you given that's
Russell's dad yeah there is how much how
much work are we
given this week to blur Jesus Christ but
that's pretty good for limp I mean he's
hanging yeah yeah that's good so
um we've turned into the British show
where they show the dick look at his
dick yeah that one checks out yeah but
no it's it's like one of those classic
cop uh cop movies where like every
cliche out of the gate with the guy's
like he's like celebrating having a beer
I got two days left on the job and then
of course immediately he goes undercover
gets [__] blown away and you're like
of course just [__] enjoy retirement
well the cliches are good when they're
the first one to do it totally like
people make fun of Seinfeld what's the
deal with but he did that he started
that so it's like let him do it and then
we all made fun of it later yeah you got
to start somewhere absolutely by the way
um he was I'm too old for this [__] he
was 41 years old here yeah well that was
a different time yeah like Mrs Robinson
I think is 39 38 hilarious the whole
movie is about her being an old bag he's
not right she's 38 years old it was a
different time well he's in in their
defense he's fresh out of college in
that movie so 22 to 38 is a big gap I
guess but I lost my virginity to a 50
something oh dude yeah we're whacking
off the [__] 65 year olds on PornHub
yeah I mean JLo's 50 he wants to hear
more about this yeah but you you know 38
so that's fine yeah but you when do you
unless you lost your virginity last year
this is a peculiar story well I did this
show in England where they no um uh no I
was 16 wow I think it was a hooker but
she didn't charge me okay on the house
and and she was how old
56 May mid-50s I'll say I didn't get the
idea hookers do like pro bono no Pro
boner yeah apparently they show he
really needs this let me give it to him
on the house I think she had a thing for
teens right and I was that's not good
well I'm I'm a Survivor I'm a victim but
I don't I'm I'm okay you're a Survivor
how did you did you and Holocaust
victims where did you meet her uh on
Bourbon Street in the French Quarter in
New Orleans yeah and what were you what
were you chatting about uh well how do
you I'm just curious how you go from age
16 I've got an image you riding your
bike do you know I mean you've just come
from Little League there this old Gil
who's just crawling she was pretty stop
would you stop and you just slam on the
brakes no I was on Bourbon Street and it
was Y2K you know was in the air and it
was New Year's Eve Eve so there was a
buzz she was SC she had a pacemaker she
thought she was going to die exactly
exactly she collapsed she hit her Life
Alert Mark showed up and he saved her it
was beautiful she looked a bit like
Merill Street yes you won dude she said
I fall and I said I can get it up so uh
I was she was on balcony flashing
everyone as a hooker does and and you
were like this is this is my dream I was
a you know a virgin 16-year-old pre-
internet porn by the way so you saw tit
and you you you you set up shop oh I
used to jerk off to like Jennifer Love
ht's cleavage that's how [__] Bleak
[__] was before internet porn like can I
get can I get a a still from I Know What
You Did Last Summer oh I did the I would
print that [__] out use all the ink on
some uh some old lady oh all the ink
yeah one in the ink two in the STI all
right
so Russell already regrets coming here I
just got a lovely image of you [__] a
printer one in the ink so desperate yeah
so um she was on a balcony flashing and
I was just staring pre- interet porn
pre- cell phone and she said she noticed
me and she said you want to come up and
I said of course and then I couldn't get
in the hotel wouldn't let me in it was
that was like your version of Carson
inviting you over to the couch
yeah yeah and they were the same age um
and uh yeah and you did a tipe five
yeah I wish more like a TI two yeah yeah
no bad closer and I didn't ex yeah was
exactly where I was going and Ed McMahon
was there but but the weird part was I
have no idea what that means but that's
clearly very well sidekick okay so uh
the weird part was she walks me to her
hotel room room 239 at the Rada Hotel
still remember and the door swings open
and there's an old guy with a white
beard and a leather jacket and a
Harley-Davidson hat staring at the door
like I don't know just in case someone
broke in he was going to be ready and
you're like that's what Santa does for
the rest of the
year yeah he left his Mall gig he was
like this will be the rest I went down
her jimney but either way he goes it was
me and two buddies and she go he goes
which one is it and she points to me and
he took my two friends on the balcony
and I was like oh we're going to get
killed we're dying this is the whole
thing and then I banged her yeah and
they went on the balcony and drank and
that was that [__] me and he just hung
out outside hung out outside and got
drunk with these two other 16-year-old
idiots wow that's an incredible so I was
15 hey and it was underneath a bridge
whoa an army camp for kids that they
thought weren't going to do well in
their exams and we kind of went there
for a week
and there were sort boys and girls and
this girl took a shining to me and she s
said oh do you want to come under the
bridge so we did it was like I had no
idea what I was doing I sort of just
grabbed a boob that was it sure and then
went like that then right and then we
started having sex it was awful and
halfway through it she looked at me and
went Boo and that scared me and I'm not
hard can you imagine that so it's the
first and only time I've ever been
inside somebody whilst that person is
giggling and oh my God it was scary and
pleasant all at the same time yeah yeah
but um and that was and then I finished
rolled over into an ant's Nest was kind
of bit to [__] went back to my friends
and was like I'm just lost my virginity
did you did you finish yeah it was
incredible we condom I was but the what
was excited about it was just it was
just that sense of going all I was
thinking was like this this is done it's
finished because I was the last out of
my friends so just yeah right so it was
just that thing of like I've just got to
get this this monkey off my back yeah
wow well but but you've trumped my story
which is normally mine is normally the
grizzli story well yearo I had red bumps
but yours were at least ant bites yeah
mine were I have a Terri I was 17 and uh
my brother just walked
in wait a minute he just walked in guy
yeah he walked in he [__] me and I I
was no longer a virgin she said get it
over with I was with a girl and he was
like come he came in drunk to [__] with
me and I was like no no no he and he was
like oh you know but I walked in on him
[__] once so we were even all right
same girl same girl okay well was it
just a date a girl you were dating kind
of thing no it was just like we were
friends and it just you know but it just
kind of happened yeah but that you know
before that you do your weird like you
know you have your hookups but like sex
for some reason took me a little longer
sure I had to do the other stuff but sex
was 15 is very young that's young but
like playing football in the UK that's
very late do you know what I mean you
sort of you know for whatever reason you
just have like my friend Steven lost it
when he was like 13 it's just insane had
a friend like that yeah and but but he
was the winner and then like as how he
doing now though is he good yeah he's
not great you know and the kid that
sometimes the kid that [__] at 13
though Peaks and and and cuz where do
you go from there yeah exactly well I'll
tell you where you go so one of my mates
Scott that I used to play upfront with
at school he lost his Virginia when he
was 13 uh and now he's found God
oh so he's gone the whole way and he was
the kid at school Whenever there was a
fight he would you'd had the fight had
to end quickly because Scott would turn
up and start fighting both people oh I
another the tape yeah he was top show he
once I remember once we were at this
sort of like this beer festival but it
was also like a jazz festival in some
bit of England a place called Hampshire
right and Scott turned to me and said we
should throw [__] at their tents oh boy
and he was so hard and so scary that
you're like yeah yeah and he went no
seriously and he put his hand in his
pocket and he had a turd from where he
get this
exactly so he he he shot in his pocket
and he threw this turd at these tents
and I was so frightened of him I was
like oh good good one man yeah and then
he kept coming up to me for the rest of
the night at this sort of Festival going
do you need to go yet oh and I was like
in a minute probably later so I had to
kind of hide from him all because he
desperately wanted me to [__] into my
hand and throw at a tent what a psych
this
is now he's found God finally so it's
it's kind of he's been on a wild Journey
which God yeah you know no one that's a
really good nobody turned around like
soon as I found God everyone still
backed away from him right because he's
[__] terrifying it could be an Isis
we don't know well you think these
people that find God they're either like
really ch or they're the most unbearable
like what did you do in your past in
your past life that you had to do this
yeah but it's I always thought with
Scott it was a bit like God taking a
footballer off before he gets a red card
do you know what I mean it was like
God's way of going okay come on exactly
enough of this you thrown enough [__]
ATT tents you need to go pre is he
married I I wouldn't I thought so okay
okay yeah he was I mean he was [__]
crazy the crazy of those guy I grew up
with guys like that not not a [__] in
the pocket that's that's a whole another
level but uh I no glove or anything he's
just hurling it bare he just took it out
of his pocket and threw it but and and
went go on then now you go and it was
just the look in his eyes he was so
angry that I hadn't got a freshly
prepared [__] in my pocket it was just
so you know it was like crazy it was
terrifying but me and him used to play
up front um playing football together so
we were kind of friends because we
played in the same position but he used
to to scare the hell out of the
opposition I'm scared of him yeah you
want that friend but I I didn't mean
interrup just say what if you cuz I
would be so nervous that I might
diarrhea and that doesn't throw well oh
[__] sorry I mean w there you go yeah
we'll get a napkin for you you're good
oh we got one but yeah I grew up with a
guys who just love to fight love to
break [__] love to terrorize and now
they're all married with kids and I'm
like how does that work yeah and what
their kids like you know terrifying yeah
right they're all on is it weird that
you're the crazy one now yeah the way
you live I mean like the way we live now
is like the [__] reckless [__] true
drinking on the road so did you guys
drink I was so curious about this do you
drink when you're on stage I drink I
drink on stage but not before right I
like to bring one out to kind of just
like have a sip but uh yeah maybe
sometimes I like one before but no I
don't I try not to I try to earn it yeah
yeah like when I did your pod I feel bad
I want to apologize I was you red wildly
hung over we had a good P but I was off
a little so I'm sorry were hilarious but
it was you're sober though I'm not sober
but I don't drink like I I've never done
a gig drunk I've never got to that like
I'll drink if I'm kind of with my mates
but I wouldn't drink at home I just
don't feel I'm sort of Super Lucky I've
got quite a few Pals who've had sort of
trouble with boots I'm so sort of EnV
like not you know the favorite fact that
I can just go I'll have a glass of wine
my friend John is just like how can you
just have one do you know what I mean
it's sort of I just don't have that kind
of urge that's a good G it's kind of
like not being attracted to kids we're
so lucky that we're not attracted cuz
that they didn't choose that you know
I'd ra i' rather I'd rather have four
glasses of wine than [__] a kid
obviously but after four never
know imagine the look of like that we've
been demonetized again yeah yeah but the
look of bafflement from the bartender if
you just had one glass of rib wine and
go I don't need another one and I don't
need to [__] kids good night Sir there's
a
tip it's called willpower yeah yeah yeah
exactly
read about it right [__] funny man just
saying you're lucky cuz I I liked it we
had one or two earlier with the our
first guest and I wouldn't mind sliding
right back into that pool it's tough
that's why I'm drinking coffee I need
that energy cuz I'm I'm doing shows
later and if I drink during the day I do
need a few coffees to get back my energy
definitely although I tell you what's
really exciting if you if you have like
an all day session and you manag to get
drunk twice that's really good fun you
know you kind of like start off and you
get a bit pissed and then you sort of
have a few coffees and then you sort of
sort of power up again later that's
impressive I mean that's why the Mad Men
stuff you're like no one of these guys
died at 58 they all got heart attacks
and you know all this [__] because they
were just drinking at noon like oh I got
a toothache let me drink oh I have a
headache let me drink oh my wife sucks
let me drink that was The Cure All but
it looked fun oh it looked great the
director for my TV show is I think like
the last kind of connection to old show
bit is because he drinks yeah like
you'll have like wine at lunch and then
wine with the main show and it's just
like he's the only person in TV that I
know and he's the director but that's
just what he does and it's just kind of
thing you know it's the old line we
always say you enjoy your your lunch
Peete you [__] drunk it quick enough
but he's that guy Liquid Lunch liquid
but like you know and you hear the bins
being empti and you like pin Pete's here
but he's the only guy I know that's like
he's really good but fully functioning
some people can do it some people can
function like that and it's a dying art
I feel like there's less unless you know
people are getting more sober now I
think but you two both like incredibly
sort consistent and prolific with booze
trying there's a lot of Shame spiraling
where I go oh I got to write more you
[__] drunk get it together yeah I
remember reading about this athlete who
used to play for the giant Jeremy shaki
remember that tight end he would get
shitfaced and then apparently just go
back to his hotel room and do like a
thousand push-ups at a guilt I feel like
Mark and I are like that but with jokes
right you know I'm just like I [__]
hate myself I got write a joke you know
do you ever see the uh maradana
documentary I haven't but yeah it's
amazing soccer player Argentinian
footballer one of the if not the
greatest of all time is he the greatest
to you yeah because like he was as good
as Messi but he was on coke what like he
was this whole documentary like in 1986
he scored some of the greatest goals
you've ever seen and he was playing for
Napoli which was a club that was then
run by the mafia and in this basically
they played on the Sunday they would win
they would take him out the mafia would
take him out drinking doing coke by
Wednesday all the other players have
been training since Monday they they get
him on a treadmill and he just runs it
off and then plays again the following
Sunday yeah incredible so if he were
sort of a dedicated athlete like now he
would be better than Messi wow but he
was he was doing all that off his box
damn it was it's a really amazing it's
by the guy that did Center yes is it on
HBO this one might be I think I saw it
some it's really the guy he's the guy
that did Senna and the Amy wi housee
documentary so yeah real pedigree when
did when did meridon pass away I feel
like
2018 let's check that no offense to him
but I do kind of respect the guys who
can do all all the blow and the drugs
and still perform well it was did yeah
yeah but what happened oh no he died
years later he played he still he still
pulled it off W he won the World Cup oh
okay he lost in life not great that I'm
fine with but the year he won the World
Cup he spent he spent the entire year
doing coke wow was like the 86 Mets they
were all on coke they were all doing
drugs one the world I mean it was like
Daryl strawberry Dwight Gooden they're
all coked out of their [__] mind
Fernandez and they won the world series
I mean there is something cool I mean I
know we should be endorsing it but Mark
is a great joke about how we celebrate
you know it's the function alcoholic
about how people are like oh he's a well
[__] him I I slept here that's his whole
thing I did I drank I did everything he
did I woke up in the office I should get
more points yes and it's it's a it's a
great observation about living that hard
and still and still pulling it off still
sticking the landing yeah like Hemingway
or or George Carlin with the cocaine
prior with the lighting himself on fire
these are all people who died extremely
young that's true well heavyweight
killed himself but yeah that's dying but
they but they leave behind a real Legacy
it's kind of and great work it's it's
like I often think about like Richard
prior you think imagine prior in the in
the age of Instagram oh my God we're
getting some good stories can you
imagine the live feeds like wow the wife
hitting alone just PRI just went on
Instagram live and I think he's on fire
yeah yeah crazy but he's shooting his
car and he's saying there might be
something in this that's why we should
be so quick I mean but it's just all
these things I'm in the woods The Twig
but like it's it would be so
demystifying of course if you saw Carlin
or prior or Hicks or something like that
every day and you're like oh okay fine
so true yeah the camera has [__] a lot
it's helped a lot of us with all the
clips and the content and the exposure
but it would have like I mean the the
[__] we get mad at people for now like
lizo shamed an employee you're like
prior beat the [__] out of his wife with
a champagne B you know Carlin's doing
blowoff of my ass we're all doing that I
mean John lennin hit his wife like I
wonder if it do you think the lizo thing
would have been a story in like the 80s
or you think it would just or would have
just come out in like a memoir or
something yeah no chance by the way I
have to break in here this is maradana
scoring a goal his coach comes out with
Coke on his wrist and gives it to him oh
my God that's a good assist coach in
blue good coach take your medicine there
you go wow that's incred incredible
Jesus Christ oh my God not exactly a
strategic Mastermind I mean that is
there is some law a some LAX drug
regulations there of like Jesus Christ
you see guys now they're like drawing
[__] up on a not guy just walks out with
a forearm Lance Armstrong like what the
[__] happened to me footballers now on
the pitch do that so that nobody can
hear or read their lips guy walks out
and says let me go against Lance
Armstrong for a second just for the sake
of argument he's taking performance
enhancing drugs these are these are
drugs that do not enhance your
performance I'd say they enhance in the
moment in the moment but your heart over
[__] time over time yeah no your
heart I don't think Coke is I mean Coke
might oh fine I've never taken Coke but
it surely it can't enhance your tell it
to Robin Williams you ever seen that
guy but I've never seen Robin Williams
play out front for Argentina and and I
listen I'd like to have seen that yeah I
would love it also if he did Coke off
his arms it get lost in the hair
but yeah no all right you got a point I
think there's a moment maybe for like
focus it it'll help you but I think for
for cardio it's got to [__] your heart
up and you're no way maybe I'm
completely wrong on this that's why
Carlin died at 71 you know yeah but
that's a decent age that's decent for 71
the older you get it doesn't feel decent
yeah we could use another special out of
Carlin yeah yeah but I'd say the last
one's good it's bad for is a good
special yeah the one before it wasn't
good it's the we talk about all the time
Norman it's great there a lot of great
jokes got some great bits in that one
he's still with it but food is worse cuz
like Ralphie May and uh Patrice O'Neal
they died way younger yeah that's Robin
Williams there and it was a much more
expensive coffin
yeah Robin Williams there he looks like
he's uh where is he there he looks like
he's done being a Dallas Cowboy Broncos
cheerleader Leah Thomas all right I'm
all thrown up
S but yeah wow that is crazy he was uh
that guy was all over the play I
guarantee he was coked up for that
moment Robin Williams yeah yeah 100%
you're right though with him doing coke
it would be like like all the hair it's
a wolf in a snow globe moment isn't it
you know what I mean there's there's a
lot going on there I met him once at the
seller Robin Williams he was the nicest
dude yeah yeah he's got such a soft
talking voice do you know those those
crazy moments when you look back so I'm
English so I don't know I wasn't aware
obviously I now know but turns out I met
Gary Shandling what at JFL and he came
up to me after a set and was being
really kind I thought he was hitting on
me and I just thought oh thanks man cool
cool but it was it was just it was a bit
like he was quite intense I like oh
thanks buddy cheers I didn't realize I
had this [__] genius genius I mean he
is but that that documentary the Gary
Shand dius is unbelievable and that bit
of advice that be morgar is such a great
bit of creative advice standups it's
whatever you are totally you have to dig
into it you I me rather than kind of go
what seems to be working at the minute
it's like be more Gary you got to
embrace your thing even though your
thing is maybe what you hate the most
about you I think with stand up the more
you can be the thing people hate about
you in regular life if you can
accentuate that in your standup you'll
be successful except for when you go
home that's true that's true and you
figured out how to and the thing that
frustr but you're right though it's it's
sort of I don't know it's that that's
what you get from that Doc it's that
sort of authenticity and he just a trer
and just a grafter and you real but all
the greats are grafters they just make
it look effortless how long after did
you realize it was Gary shaning or
realize it was when I literally it was
years later I remember seeing Seinfeld
interview him and I was like on
Comedians in Cars yeah so you never saw
Larry Sanders
I'm rewatching it currently it's so good
but this is what I mean so then I like
it's so frustrating that you I don't
know even Seinfeld the sitcom didn't
really break in the UK wow yeah it's
just not really a thing yeah so there's
certain so as who who are guys for you
that were like well like this is the
this is our these are our guys like
you're equivalent to Jerry like to you
not a stand up probably there's a guy
called Frank Skinner or Billy Connelly
is probably
Scot guy but he was I would say he's
Connelly is the sort of Carlin figure
he's like the nation's brother then
Uncle then Granddad do you know what I
mean that he he's the one that everybody
loved yeah and still like I got to
interview him on my show and it was so
thrilling to kind of make this guy laugh
Frank skin is a really great English
comic uh he has a sort of chat show but
it's that similar thing
where there's just certain people that
just don't
like obviously Seinfeld's huge but I'd
be I'd be very interested when he gigs
in the UK I bet you they're mostly
Americans yeah I'd say so you know what
I mean it's sort of that thing of like
that his humor just wouldn't have
traveled we just don't have that culture
as much but yet friends was massive it's
kind of bizarre oh interesting it's
amazing Seinfeld's it's great 20 times
to show the friends but no it's very New
York it's very Jewish I think it is
definely a little more NE so bigger and
and maybe it's much more vanilla it is
and that's that's like McDonald's that's
going to sell more I think and it's just
so kind of there's just there's no
earthiness there's no kind of it just
you can feel the creativity through
committee whereas Seinfeld you feel
Larry David you just yeah yeah but you
just feel those two just kicking it back
it's much jeer humor as well and there's
just less Jews I think like like that
type of humor in America is very broad
but we loved it we that's my point is
that I think that's very Jewish humor in
America is like look back at how Mel
Brooks yeah Allen it's very that's very
Broad in America yeah well it's even
like the you know just to come on stage
and go I shot a moose you know that
feels like it's such a like it's such a
wildly surreal premise and yet kind of
and yet in America like there we go you
know what I mean very interesting I love
the Woody Allen this such a perfect joke
do you ever see played Again Sam no
there's a great scene where he goes up
to a woman in the museum you know what
I'm talking about amazing he goes up to
hit on a woman and he goes uh you know
what do you you can play it too it might
be it might be I'm not going to do it
justice it might be funnier but uh yeah
Museum scene his joke still hold up like
people go oh comedy really ages Woody
Allen jokes still hit they're still
great same as those Shandling gags man
here it is yeah go back a minute yeah
the Gary Shand oh yeah still work here
it is
no a little further
back it restates the little further back
what do you think of this painting okay
it's a very simple start black and white
just scrapes on a
wall what does it say to you it restates
the negativeness of the universe the
Hideous lonely emptiness of existence
nothingness the predicament of man man
forced to live in a Barren Godless
eternity like a tiny flame flickering in
an immense void with nothing but waste
horror and degradation forming a useless
Bleak straight jacket in a black absurd
Cosmos what are you doing Saturday night
coning
suicide what about Friday
night that's great that's just a great
joke that's a great joke she killed it
too by the way she [__] nailed that
monologue but yeah what about mon python
was that was that uh again not really a
thing it wasn't so the films Life of
Brian uh Hill Grail um meaning your life
they were played and you had a video and
you saw those but the series was never
on TV what like we only had four
channels when I was growing up so they
just didn't 40 Towers never shown how
about how about the office the office
yeah so the office was that was so
what's that that's 98 so that would have
been I just started doing standup and it
was yeah that was like seminal but that
was so great it just felt so original
and it feels so English I know obviously
the American office has done it so well
but like that first one is so like even
the way jaice looks then like you know
what I mean he just doesn't look he
doesn't look like somebody like that guy
isn't getting him friends you know what
I mean and he just all of them that the
voice perfectly matches the body yes you
know it's so there it's so well cast
it's so funny can I say this about and
had that cringe factor which the
American one has but this one had it on
steroids the problem this guy too is so
great that the cool boss he's incredible
but what's amazing is that that
basically like javice affected comedic
acting I would say in the world but
definitely in the UK but that kind of
stilted so well you know oh yeah like
you see that all the time where people
instead of doing sort of punch lines
it's just that W you know n yeah do you
know what I mean that kind of drifty
[__] totally totally where did he come
from he was weirdly he used to manage
bands my tour manager yeah my tour
manager Kumar knows him because he used
to manage uh bands at UCL which is a can
you imagine having a manager that funny
yeah man just that I mean he just I mean
geez this even his face like the face
the movements the way he bites his lip
it's all great oh come
on uh
and you got to hand it to Michael Scott
or not Michael Scott Steve Carell
because he he made it his own somehow oh
this is so iconic it's rare to see it
remade and still be funny in a new way
totally but it must have been so hard
filming that can you imagine that like
there's a reason those cutaways are done
in singles yeah do you know what I mean
because I mean this it's just this sad
rivalry he has with the better looking
boss I always think of the scene where
the boss is always wearing like cool
designer stuff at Jas walks and he's
like this jacket Sergio georgini yeah
yeah like what who is that it's so funny
but it Taps into the ego and it's how
insecure people are and how uh we just
want to be loved there's so much more to
of the office than my brother my brother
couldn't be more uh David Brent if he
tried he's so yeah he's so funny he told
a story the other day to my friend Steve
that used to write on my TV show he was
kind of go yeah I was in the office the
other day just and My Brother Talks as
if he's a comic he could he could be a
comic he's you know he's funny enough
but he kind of yell was in the office
the other day doing a bit of gear and um
you know they didn't laugh and I kind of
went up to them and I was like why
aren't you laughing and they said oh it
was just too funny so we're going to
laugh later like but that could be a
scene from The Office like yeah totally
so the way my brother now retells
stories he'll just he'll he'll say what
he said and then and then I said this
and everyone's like laugh laugh laugh
laugh laugh Applause shut up but so he
kind of self- congratulates himself
really fascinating but that's what I
mean it's there's a lot of guys that
kind of leared how to ape jaes yeah do
you know what I mean and it's kind of
like in sort of certainly in sort of
sitcoms in the UK it really affected
them hasn't been many much great stuff
since oh but like you know what I mean
who who else were you guys as a as as a
standup as a standup so it started off
it was Connelly I'd say Frank Skinner
and then kind of once I got into standup
when I was about sort of 16 I kind of
got into like Hicks and kind of Richard
Pryor and then belatedly Carlin I got
into and then isard I guess you know
what I mean and um yeah and then those
were really then once I kind of started
doing the circuit it was Ross Noble and
Daniel kitson with the two kitson you
seen kitson I've never seen him but I've
heard he's excellent incredible so basic
I was so lucky so they used to be thing
called The Comedy Network which is where
You' sort of tour universities in the UK
and I supported Daniel um on two tours
it was incredible so he you know the
best comic in the UK and I was 22 and I
got to go on and do 20 minutes and then
he would go on and do an hour and it
would change every night and it just you
know that thing when you're sort of
particular when you're starting stand up
and you're figuring it out yeah and you
get to do a set and it goes well and
then you get to sit down and watch your
Genius and kind of study them he people
talk about like braveart he was 7 fo
tall tall he was he's really great he
won't do TV right he's got all these
weird why why is it I I don't know
really it's sort of like like he's he's
a bit of a sort of a a Salinger figure I
think and I he's so he turns it over so
much so he was at the End Festival this
year with a completely new show I mean
honestly I I'm not kidding I think he's
probably written saler Rel book one book
only you know Fran and Zoe Fran and Zoe
and then once had catch in the right
that was it my point and there was one
has probably but he's probably written
35 hours 35 hours like I would genuinely
and that some of them are on band camp
but he just does them live and if you're
kind of in the gang and you've seen him
you kind of know but I mean look at him
he's like he's funny looking he's clever
he has a stutter he's a great guy yeah
he's just one of yeah explain the
stutter so does that is that distracting
on stage or he doesn't stutter on stage
but he only stutters up off off stage
amazing so he yeah he used to have you
know he had loads of stuff on it and
then by the time he was like 25 he he
walk on St hello my name is Daniel I've
got a stutter take it on trust I've got
our of funny stuff on it let's move on
right but you know just had this kind of
just utter confidence he's he's the word
genius is slung around a lot but when
you see him in full flow he is really
something else so I got to support him
and then the other guy I was supporting
was John Oliver so pretty luy really
just in terms of and then you know those
they were the my kind of like beers you
know I mean that's who I was aiming for
it was great so cool yeah I only learned
I learned a lot from Cosby's later work
yeah it was terrific yeah but wow that's
incredible what a what a learning
experience yeah it was amazing man so
but those and Ross Noble like he was
like a brilliant uh sort of in
improvising comic great great sort of
surreal comic he was huge huge in the
naughties still going now he's great but
was like you know just would improvise
the whole thing and and just a brilliant
brain I feel bad cuz I I went to England
recently and i' would bring up I'd be
hanging out with local comics and I'd
bring up a guy I'd heard of and they all
went oh oh really yeah I don't want to
say names but you know all the famous
not like a Jimmy Carr Jimmy Carr is
great but you bring up a guy where
you're like oh I'll show him I know this
guy they'll be impressed and they're
like oh that guy's the worst oh you've
got to tell me that what's the reaction
tell what's the reaction I will and we
can cut this it's time to get a fresh
face for fall the handyman manscapes
electric face shaver let you get a brand
new start it tackles up to three days of
growth without the need for a wet shave
their skin safe technology even helps
reduce Nicks and cuts so you feel
confident going in for that close shave
I use it I bring it on the road with me
it's great it keeps this beard tight I
don't want to look like Abe linoln but
you know don't want to feel like Abe
stinking keeps it clean clean nice and
we'll cut that part it features a 5
minute quick charge for when you're
short on time and it's rechargeable
battery lasts a full 60 minutes that's
good yeah it never really dies it's
compact so it won't take up tons of
space in the drawer and it's airplane
friendly so you can take it on the go
true get 20% off and free shipping with
the code drunk at manscape.com that's
20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code drunk hit the
refresh button with a handyman I love it
it's all I wear it's in my travel bag
and I wore their underwear to the sex
club thank you manscape hey hey we might
be drunk is brought you by fume baby
some habits can die really die hard fume
is here to help switch to something that
takes the bad out of the bad habit fume
is an Innovative award nominated device
that gets you looking at your Habit in a
whole new way instead of electronics
fume is completely natural instead of
vapor it uses flavored Air instead of of
harmful chemicals it uses all natural
flavors what you get to keep is activity
the activity itself with movable parts
and magnets for fidgeting fume helps you
de-stress while you work to break your
habit it is just fun to play with this
thing it's fun to hold I like to suck on
it and I'm talking about Sam but with an
adjustable airflow dial and awesome
flavors to choose from ditching a bad
having could be fun stopping is
something we all put off cuz it's hard
but switching to fume is easy enjoyable
and even fun it served over 100,000
customers has thousands of success
stories and there's no reason that can't
be you join fume in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to trif nume.com and use code
drunk to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today that's TR rfu m.com
and use code drunk to save an additional
10% off your order today fume
fume I was a door guy at Broadway and
and I remember hearing Mike D Stefano
who since passed was a very funny guy he
made a comment about being a dirty comic
but he was like uh you know but then he
was talking about [__] he's like [__]
Bill Cosby you know he's a piece of [__]
right and Mike D Stefano was like rough
around the edges but you could tell he
was like a decent guy yeah what is this
whole thing with like being a dormant
like it's a way in but so you just work
the door yeah but that's so strange what
do you guys do in the UK you you do an
open spot well you get to do spots if
you do the door sure but you didn't have
to do that you could just have a a job
it's American labor yes but it's but
were you were you paid in spots or were
you paid money as well I was spot just
spots so time yeah but there's so many
comedians that why I give you a spot but
you have to act as security yeah I
didn't do I didn't do a very good job I
mean remember one time Jessica K was on
stage like he's going to throw people
out that's what I mean but it's just
like like it doesn't really help you
saying that but imagine at least you're
tall but you know I'm not a particularly
tall guy it's just the idea that you're
like [__] me I've got like well actually
people one time I got sped on on stage
there cuz I I worked the door you got
spat on and then I and then I went on
stage they were talking he was just
talking to me yeah no I got uh I went on
stage and this guy wouldn't stop
heckling me I was like dude come on like
at a certain point and then I start
trashing him and he go he just gets up
and I'm like oh [__] what's going to
happen here and the weight staff like me
cuz they knew me so they kind of
barricade the stage he stops and I just
hear and I'm like a crap per terrible
people of perfect aim hits me right here
I was like oh and uh and then I was like
well I guess I got to throw him out now
too oh God Jesus did you no he left they
wage was like he got to go the only time
I've had a fight playing football when I
was a kid someone spat in my face and I
just properly just went for him and then
could you can you fight no but he
subsequently beat the [__] out of me he
was clearly baiting me but he just
went [__] and then the spit on is very
tough cuz you got to stand your ground
man you can't it's not even I don't even
think you think it's the most it's the
most visceral right okay we have to go
now it's just the contempt of the where
was the teammates on you I was up front
so so when you play up front you kind of
on your own it was just me and this
Defender Sports the fight's not supposed
to actually happen team you're supposed
to you're supposed to look tough and
they jump in and this this thing is cuz
it was just a football game at College
it's not like there was a crowd who
could see it there were just like just
he like beat me up and then I just got
up know flag or anything no exactly and
then I was there what happened yeah I
spat on me and I hit him and then he hit
me a lot harder yeah anyway I we just
carried on playing how great would that
be if the the goalie jumped in no yeah
man it was
just that's a goalie so how often do you
come to the US so uh this is my third
tour um so I opened for him in 09 01
something crazy exactly yeah where did
you open for him I think it was at the
Hammerstein Ballroom whatever the one is
on the west side we did did yeah we did
that and we did like Gotham a couple of
times so maybe it's the fourth and then
not Gotham uh gramy oh yeah that is a
great room great room that is a great
room and then we did the town hall last
time so um town hall is classic yeah
it's amazing it's kind of so it's just
we're doing like an East Coast tour we
sort of zigzagged we did like 35 shows
in 33 days last year with a bus and it's
just you like the tour bus no it was
just too much because it just it meant
it should mean something particularly
from the if you're from the UK If you're
doing a gig in Chicago and people have
come to see you and I grew up in Bristol
in the UK yeah or you wherever you are
in America you're in SE yeah you're in
La it's exciting but doing that many
shows that quickly you just it's like
where are
we and you suddenly realize this isn't
the way to do it so what I'm trying to
do now is just do like hopefully like a
15 date run and then go home and then
later on in the year I'll do like the
middle and then later on try and do the
sort of West Coast and just try and it's
not even to kind of like [__] break
it or whatever it's just it's like we
were saying earlier it's just to make
you better as a comic you just got put I
like putting my stuff through different
cultures totally you know I mean and
just sort of seeing where it kind of
fits and you kind of find that the
basics work everywhere humans are just
humans you know you make a fat joke and
they're going to laugh cuz they know fat
people oh you look at like ancient Greek
comedy from like 4,000 BC they're making
like dick fart and jokes and you're like
oh this is this is the oldest comedy
yeah exactly well it's like like you say
that Roman documentary you're watching
all the graffiti is just [__] and do you
know what I mean it's EX so kind of your
wife's a [__] yeah but it's it's those
kind of kind of things you know they've
always been I mean that's what's so kind
of maddening at the minute is this kind
of this odd sort of attempt to kind of
for one of another word clean up comedy
it's like it's absurd because if you
watch like documentary from World War II
there's a brilliant one by the guy that
did Billy Elliot the film and there's
footage of just these very English
looking men kind of like bony faed is
wonky teeth and whatnot and they're just
chatting about so the sergeant major
right we're there right we're about to
go on a salute and he's he's falling
over in a bucket of [__] and they're all
like laughing cuz they're in war and
their mates tripped in a bucket of [__]
and it just shows you the kind of
importance of that just the release
valve totally we now live in an era
where there's different types of thing
it's that's what's so frustrating that
somehow comedy has to be for the
mainstream it has to be one thing
right exactly the genres there's no yeah
but we know the genre and yet somehow
it's like you know it's literally like
if like you can only have Marvel movies
yeah yeah exactly man or it's like but
like look at music you've got like guys
singing about the devil and Harry Styles
singing about watermelon that doesn't
but yeah but music isn't just music you
know what I mean it's it's allowed a
sort of a variation of scales that for
some reason it all comes down to well it
was comedy and I was supposed to laugh
and you're like well yeah other people
did it's like we try to do it a little
like people go it's Urban night like
yeah but Hannibal sounds a lot different
different than Bruce Bruce or earthquake
you know but also that's what's
frustrating about that is whenever you
try and bunch it that also doesn't work
where you're like it's the dark comedy
night and then you're like okay it's
going to be jokes about disabled people
and it's going to be dwarf jokes and
Hitler and pedophiles and of dark comedy
sure but my point being if you if you
see that over and over and over and over
it's going to be a bit boring the the
great thing about standup audiences live
are intelligent enough to go hey that
was [__] hilarious actually that
mainstream guy was really funny hey that
girl was really cool they don't give a
[__] funny but for some reason it's
whenever it's kind of repackaged sort of
put through this it's always by people
that don't get what we do and and
there's always what's frustrating the
only time that Comics seem to make the
news is when it's a joke that gets in
trouble and you you never have the
article audience go to watch standup
really enjoyed it can't remember half of
it it was fun of course is the you know
right in my night my mom was sick and
now I feel better yeah you know they
never say that article but the the same
thing goes with diversity we got to have
divers but it's like if eight guys sound
like John meany who are different races
it's not diverse it's the same
[__] I watch meany's there's some
beautiful noises coming from that door I
know right I'm actually a huge fan of
black melany that guy awes terrific he
um oh Johnny Mack he's good the uh the
his I saw Hisense I saw his live show
and there's a bit in it where he's on
about his dad losing his job have you
seen that and he's he's wants to get
loads of photos of them together as a
family you know there that the latest
one yeah when your dad starts breaking
down and goes we need family photos and
he's just kind of goes just [__] face
the camera and smile and he just looks
to his brother and goes this guy's not
doing too well and it's just this
beautiful bit yeah I thought I really
enjoyed that show I thought it was great
it was sort of just a it's it's a kind
of it's weirdly it's a real romp through
being a drug drug addict do you know
what I mean it's kind of really funny
but it's not and then inevitably all the
reviews like why didn't he go deep
enough and you're like cuz people don't
want that man you know what I mean why
don't these reviewers tell a guy who's
mastered this [__] what he did wrong we
need more of that no I mean John melany
is is every comic loves melany that's
why it was so interesting to me when
people no matter who you are no matter
what you do there will be a mob after
you at some point and it's interesting
it's like this guy played it pretty
clean he had a divorce people had this
opinion on him and it was kind of like
people that's human nature though people
enjoy it they want to prop you up then
take you down then they prop you up
again they do they do but it was an
interesting one to me where I was like
yeah people get divorced this is not you
know this is kind of this is life and uh
a man make a mistake people can make
mistakes not be horrible people you
can't judge them a whole person's
character on one
snafu yeah I mean I just think it's it's
interesting I mean he's got he got
interesting material out of it too out
of the it's great out of the drugs and
everything that's what comedy supposed
to do like I saw videos of the Ukraine
war on Tik Tok and these soldiers are
like [__] with each other and you're
like yeah this guy might say [__] or
something but they need this they're
they're at War they're head off we got
to cancel this dude man this guy me get
rid of these dudes mate well I've got
funny enough I've got a bit in my show
exactly about that about seeing little
old ladies making missiles and giggling
right and you kind of go of course
they're giggling like if you're in a war
making missiles trying to destroy Putin
you you need a laugh can I have a
release yeah come on but yeah let me let
me say what I two things I noticed about
England that are different than here
okay one you're less agist right I will
I'll go to I went to a pub just about
every night I went to a pub and there'd
be like a 22 y old guy hanging out with
like a 61y old guy and it was completely
normal right it wasn't like just father
and son I don't know I mean they look
different they they were pounding it up
and then you see like an older woman
with a younger guy or whatever and it
was or a group of people and they're all
different ages yeah we don't have that
here really that's interesting yeah I
was going to say New York feels like a
very young City it just feels like you
get to a certain age and someone knocks
on the door and you're like you got to
get out now yeah that's it you're done
you're too ugly that's very interesting
that we kind of they go to Florida
what's the other thing the other thing
was uh you allow ugly people on TV way
more than us sure sure you got some
newscasters I was like who Jesus what is
this horror movie oh it's the it's the
six o00 news yeah we think it softens
the blow here of a woman with a lot of
makeup to so funny man the thing that
gets me with with your news it always
makes me laugh that there are adverts in
between the news that is such it's just
such a funny way of telling
people been been a hurricane and many
people are dead do you want to buy a car
like you never talk like that it's such
a strange way of relaying really
important stuff so true big Pharma pays
for 75% of uh news like that's keeping
it on hence hence all the adverts for
medicine exactly that's why it is that
and it's not going to change cuz they're
like we need this otherwise we'd go off
the air uh TV is dying I mean Sports
when Sports goes away from TV that could
really be trouble sport on Amazon now
like you can already you know Amazon's
already got Thursday night football and
you kind of Wonder oh do they I mean yes
you wonder when that's going to make the
full transition because yeah that I I
wonder what do people W have you ever
scrolled through live cable and you're
like this is it's like primitive suck
[__] you go to pass Bravo some [__]
[__] on a yacht this is a show below
deck whatever that's a huge show oh my
God it's awful but uh you know you see
the [__] you're scrolling patch you're
like how the [__] is this scull pass TLC
and you're like I don't want to watch a
600 lb person just be sad this is your
show it's huge but it's it is and
presumably with the writer strike
there's going to be six months of that
well I think they're winning I think
they won they won WG one yeah sure but
the point I'm making so there been six
months where they've been doing nothing
sure so there's going to be a whole lot
there's going to be a whole lot of
reality there's going to be a lot of men
on TLC falling in love with their car
yeah like we did a sketch about that
years ago on on the show was about this
guy called Chase who was married to his
car and he was talking to his dad about
it and he was and we we did this sketch
um very simple sketch and I it's the
most I've ever seen my dad laugh and the
most horrified I've ever seen my mom CU
I knew this sketch was coming so it's
basically he tells his dad and his dad's
like you're in a loving relationship
with your car that's fine and then it
comes back to me in the studio and I'm
like that would have been very different
with my dad cuts to the sketch and I go
Dad I'm in love with the car my dad
punches me and I fall to the floor and
he says why can't you be more like your
brother and it cuts to my brother my
actual brother with his ass out [__]
a
motorbike and like really kind of
hammering it and my mom my mom was
horrified that my brother had done it
she's like Dan why did you let him do
that my dad I thought he was going to
die man that's good it's weird though
isn't it it's sort of that the the the
kind of the Mania of reality TV is I
mean where do you go for that because
that's Now sort of drifted into
Instagram that's all it is it's just
people sharing
anything and just like so you have The
Madness of cable but that's exactly the
same as Tik Tok or Instagram it's just
desperate people trying to create a
brand and telling you everything you
sort of realize how lucky we are that
the great thing is we get to put clips
of standup online or photos of you you
dressed in leather whatever whatever
sells but but but the point is you get
to you get to put that out you
don't but you're putting out funny
things that you've created it is great
rather than this thing of like could
this be my thing is this my thing that
you that will make you like me oh you're
saying we're lucky cuz we know our thing
know what's interesting also about that
is when you're scrolling on like an
explore page on Instagram or whatever
you're using Tik Tok and you're s it's
all tis and nor McDonald because it's
tailored to you exactly cable is not
tailored to you that's what cable is
competing with so you're just going it's
either you're going random [__] or
you're like well this knows what I like
yeah and that's and that you're not
winning that battle no you are not
that's so true it's uh it's pretty scary
but it's going to win but if you watch
something before bed how often is it
like you scrolling what what I watch
before bed I'm like let me watch
something tried and true yeah so they'll
make me laugh and put me at ease that's
interesting cuz I I can't watch stuff
that makes laugh before I go to bed I
get too kind of amped Up by it the same
way so me and my wife we so we've
watched Mad Men that's our show over and
over and over and it's this kind of
weirdly Mad Men westwing uh and The
Sopranos American TV baby on well the
but the box sets the wire just but um
have you seen the wire's tough before
bed that's a downer but but seen it if
you've seen it so many times it becomes
comforting yeah and it's slow it's slow
you me no I've definitely watched it's
probably because of how many times I've
seen The Sopranos but like you see an
episode where a guy gets his face beaten
in with a golf club and you're like all
right I'm going to bed it's time for bed
that's what I mean it's not like where
is Richie AI [__] with the but it's
like it's even watching watching stuff
like i' I've come to the party late and
it's not really a party but top boy I've
started watching top boy everybody loves
top boy yeah it's great thank you by the
way that killed what the top top boy
it's like their wire oh yeah it's it's a
huge show in the UK and my wife has
Kevin Spacey tuned in he was very
disappointed yeah he's like this is a
complete Miss yeah but he uh the it's
it's really good but it's so tense when
you don't know what's going to happen
you you know it's it's a hard watch
before you're about to go to bed yeah
can I take a big leap in a convo so you
mentioned like not have you you can pick
everything's catered to you I would say
that's good and exciting but it's not
great in the regular world it's good for
entertainment but I think that's why
we're kind of kind of in the dating
crisis we're at we're in because you
used to meet the girl next door the girl
at work the girl at school and now it's
like why would I go with her I could
have all this it it makes it harder to
settle there well yeah the options on
your phone dming all that stuff exactly
and it's all catered to you and it's
never ending basically and it creates a
fomo that you kind of feel like yeah
exactly I'm married look at this chick's
fake ass I could I could have that I
know and she's in it my area you know
according to this she's single and horny
so yeah it it's tough there's too many
options like you go to a diner you know
when you go to a diner it's like all
right they got pancakes they got eggs
they got bacon they got coffee great
give me the pancakes but you ever go to
those diners with like 900 pages and
you're like I don't know you can't read
the page you got to know what you want
you got to just sit down and go tuna
melt you got do it that's it but you
don't have those in the UK believe me
the American Diner and the blizzard of
options yes is it's so great like I love
it okay good I was worried you're going
to trash
because you don't we don't have it so
it's like I'm the opposite so I get
there and you're like oh America look at
that you can have fries for breakfast
you crazy [__] Al but I get honestly
like the breakfast in this country is
just Exquisite if you go to a diner what
do you get usually a diner I kind of so
I was going to this place called the
gray dog in Chelsea oh I know the gray
dog love the gray dog good sandwiches
yeah yeah I had um I had an omelette
today with feta uh caramelized onion
mushrooms you don't have that no oh
caramelized onion in the morning no
English person's going to caramelize an
onion you guys can dominate a India you
can't get a [__] meal together what's
going on we can get a meal but it's the
care and the options that go into yeah
you guys you you know you have some
beautiful ornate architecture you got
you got cool cars over there yeah we can
do like I said the other day I think
Indian food British Indian food is we do
that really well that's the only Cuisine
I think we uh you're good Chinese yeah
it's all right but it's it's but that
like our Indian food is next level did
you have any curries while you were
there I had a bunch and I went to a
place in Hackney in that area right by
the the theater I can't remember the
name but it got recommended by like 50
people was it did was it like a bring
your own beer place I don't know it had
two floors and it was really pretty and
had like a real um I bet you yeah I
think I know the place you mean it's
Ambiance what do you have I got the
curry that's but yeah you can't just say
the curry well it was Curry or tikka
masala I was going to Mony it up W all
right so you went straight down the
middle yeah my buddy got the Tikka so we
did a little sharing I should have I
should have taken you because I wanted
to come to your show but I was being
truthful my dog was having surgery
because your dog is 15 you said he's 15
he's 105 if he was a if he was a man and
he's he's had to have that night that I
was going to watch your show he had um
four teeth removed and the basic the vet
had to say look there's a chance that he
may not come around so that was the day
we did the podcast so you were hung over
and I was petrified my dog was dying oh
so I think with that in mind we did all
right yeah she she just said surgery too
it sucks I mean I was trying to work on
a bit about how like pet how uh vet is
the weirdest job cuz you have to deliver
horrible news for the silliest names
great you just come in like
unfortunately waffles has a malignant
tumor you know but it's like you you get
into you get into is a great pet name
you get into being a vet because you
know you love animals and then you have
to do this but like that's the majority
of it is just putting them to sleep
exactly but like if you're a doctor
that's you don't get into being a doctor
CU I love humans I I disagree my wife's
a doctor she loves people and she works
in elderly care and she loves people she
I feel I don't think that's the general
I don't think most people I disagree
maybe not in America but they I think we
all just hate people here we but you you
don't get well paid to be a doctor in
the UK so it has to these guys have got
brains very similar to Comics brains by
the way it's just that we have access to
ridiculous information they have access
to life Saab but for example they could
see a bone and go okay that needs this
this this and this whereas you hear the
word mango and you're like I remember
that thing do you know what I mean it's
it's it's a similar kind of memory
retrieval system but my wife works in
elderly care love and to me that's
mind-blowing because she's never going
to win yeah because there at the end but
she just adors hanging out with them and
hearing the stories and and a lot of her
friends are the same they just they they
it's a real Quest and a real love for
people it's [__] strange sa a life I
think nurses here care about people
where doctors are sort of like the
mechanics of people the nurses they get
I bet you honestly man I don't know I
mean Maybe I'm Wrong maybe because a pet
though a pet you're like a I got to put
down waffles but I got to put down
Shelly you got to know Shelly you
learned about her life and we had had a
conversation where they never had a
conversation I think some of it might be
protective too where you're like if if
you're a doctor and you care about
people that's got to be [__]
exhausting well that's it what you do
you but you I guess the by care it's
that thing of it's helping them on their
Journey towards death and knowing that
enough is enough and so they've got a
pragmatic kind of logical approach to it
rather than we've got to make them live
forever it's like listen they're going
to be in agony come on enough's enough
and they're night yeah do you know it is
it's it's um but yeah it's it's [__]
fascinating like being married to a
doctor is uh yeah it's what kind of
doctor Elderly Care and acute medicine
so she deals with old people and
stabbings so that is a that's a real
merry go around so uh old people who who
are living tough yeah
exactly just Haggard old gang members
string around but yeah it's it's kind of
um it's cool and they're all married
it's so funny because doctors all
married each other so she's the only one
that's kind of married to a comic very
it's a it's a tough life imagine that
imagine being a doctor and being married
to a [__] comedian it's the most
serious job in the world and the
silliest job in the world but yet she
has to deal with a man that takes his
silly job seriously yeah imagine that's
the only way to do it yeah but like you
mean she's dealing with death and I'm
like I just can't make this joke like
waffles that's a funny I feel like so
much of this in the early stages is you
know at least for Mark and myself I
think we were like we'll get drunk all
the time and then you realize the work
you have
to have a career and you're like holy
[__] you have to take it seriously you
know what's really exciting for you guys
so I was I saw Nick Offerman leave
because he's just done the podcast and
he said to his assistant I really admire
those guys yeah yeah he went he went
really and this is genuinely true I'm
not blowing smoke out your eyes he went
they're incredible those two young men
they're incredible so yeah I just wrote
a 20-minute bit of a ball bags yesterday
you know well that's you might have been
saying that in the lift I
we feel the same way about him he's an
awesome guy but it was really nice hey
and it was sort of I don't know it was
it must have been really cool incredibly
talented and cool guy so that was that
was awesome yeah no he's uh we're
slumming it yeah no okay so vulgar life
is good man [__] animal bit that was
half a bit there I had to think about
peeves half a
bit I like that very funny some peeves
yeah yeah I was told I had to do some
work so no pressure no hey hey Wonder
box is no is it Wonder box yeah yeah I
had to do some homework for that so
we're even yeah let me have a look uh
peeves I guess peeves too okay do you
want to go first I'll go first there you
go I think I used mine on the last one
let me try I got peev I got peeves for
days my friend yeah I've written quite I
got one um how about this when people
say don't be mad and then they they're
about to deliver you bad news like you
don't get to tell me how to feel yes I
[__] hate it's always the biggest
[__] [__] called too he's like
don't be mad you're like all right what
is it he goes I borrowed your car and I
ran over an old lady by accident and
you're like okay well I guess I can't be
mad now you told me it's a bit like when
like when someone says the phrase well I
was going to say do you have that here
well I was going to say yeah you just
did your [__] [__] you know what I
mean I was going to say you just did
like the one that gets me is when you
hear again I don't know if this is a
phrase but you it's normally some old
[__] AB bargain well I've heard it
all now and you're like you haven't
never left this bar you know what I mean
but it's always some guy who's seen it
all and they've never left their
Hometown it's like when they go you
can't make that up you're like well we
got Harry Potter Star Wars Lord of the
Rings you could make some [__] up your
story about the dry cleaning not being
ready is not that mind you can make
stuff up here's the thing here's the
thing that I was thinking is like a a a
topical peeve if you will but Taylor
Taylor Swift making the news just
because she cheered at a football game I
don't get it Janet Jackson got a t out
come on now well who defend she made the
news I've jerked off to both to be fair
but the effort that goes in yeah to to
doing a dance and then getting your tit
out if she'd have known all she had to
do was cheer him on she is the biggest I
mean you know what it's the biggest be
really careful I know still come after
you I actually saying I was actually
about to compliment her she's the
biggest star in the world for touring
right now if she does so if she if she
does it also it is funny to watch the
NFL just like bow down to her like
literally you turn they realize they're
tapping into a whole new fan base but
that's what I mean it's incredible but
it's the respect that Americans have for
celebrity that's what blows my mind it's
not a celebrity it's her because if at
that game there was Hugh Jackman Paul
run Ryan Reynolds there's all these
celebrities there and no they didn't
[__] mention any of them it's h the
kids win the teens win they are the the
most coveted demographic and she's got
it but it was it was it just reminded me
when David Beckham was first going out
with Posh Spice which I guess is the
equivalent of Victoria beckam the crowd
that day chanted and there was 880,000
people in the stadium does she take it
up the ass and they they chanted that at
him the choreography is every week for
the rest of his career until he left
until he left England his fans yeah oh
like and he's one of our greatest
footballers but that's what I mean but
picture but it's the lack of respect we
have for celebrities picture of it all
comes
out things over their face Alex
Rodriguez the baseball player had he
hooked up with Madonna right and the
fans in the crowd they all have Madonna
things over their
faces but that's what I mean you kind of
need that kind of humor in do you know
what I want to see what because it kept
cutting to Taylor at the football I
cannot wait for the footage of when he
he has to go to one of her gigs and they
cut to him because he looks like a man
that does not know her lyrics like no
that's how he met he went to her concert
oh really yeah I because he made yeah
well here's the thing uh also I my issue
with the it's not Taylor Swift it's
Taylor Swift's
fans are humorless you can't make a joke
about her or they come after you guess
what they're like you're going after
Taylor Swift yeah she's a billionaire
now I'm making a joke about her okay she
can handle it popular person in America
I went on a show I made a joke faking
that we were dating and I had a
Photoshop thing saying like we used to
date and it was a picture of her at the
at the uh Chief's game but instead of a
Chief's shirt it was a samarel shirt and
we doctored it and we did a whole thing
pretending like it was real and the
newscasters were great they played along
it was a dumb gag so funny and I posted
it and so many of the swifties came
after me in the comments like like this
is this is not cool this you don't go
after someone like this I'm like the
most famous person yes am I not allowed
to make fun of [__] Biden or Trump
anymore now she's the female Trump the
Trump people will come after you hard
it's the same thing same
hair her it's her the audience is what
I'm saying yeah of course yeah because
she would like she clearly has a good
sense of humor you tell she's got lots
of mate she doesn't take herself like
her videos are funny so yeah she can
laugh but it's like you get this what
weirdly I did exactly the same on the
news this lady was saying the other day
so um how's the show going when I'm
pretty excited Taylor Swift's coming and
she was like oh is she and I was going I
just said that so I can sell out like
that but she was and then I kind of yeah
I was chatting about how the fact I just
found it fascinating that it made the
news the day your government nearly shut
down that's so funny yeah you know what
I mean bigger story but it's a bit like
when like when Biden was trying to make
sure billionaires um paid more tax than
nurses yeah you know when he released
that it was the day after uh Will Smith
slapped Chris Rock at the ospice so
nobody was speak but it was just that
thing it was just I just really you
should have had Will Smith slap Diane
Feinstein before she died gotten some
attention but it's just like just wait a
week and let it die down and then but it
just yeah well that's how obsess we
celebrity that that is bigger than
Presidential news you know and that's
why the president uses celebrity he'll
be like well so and so is on my side and
we go oh they are I didn't know you had
Brad Pit I got one here so in terms of
peeve the word
right like just everywhere like and
we've only just started getting it like
takes us 5 years we're now doing oh you
just got there yeah and it's [__]
everywhere now there was a headline I
saw the other day that said woke
Scrabble bosses ban the word fart and
boobies what exactly but again it's just
there to get people no they've come for
Scrabble now you can't but just the idea
Potato Head yeah then the mermaid but
like the cops are breaking a door down
he's got Tri click on a triple letter
it's just so ridiculous by the way a guy
playing boobies and scrab one you're
just like I challenge yeah but he also
should be you'll say you'll put anything
down to win yeah yeah come on I play
Words I love playing Words with Friends
I'll do it on my phone all the time I
love that game yeah but it's just you
know it's like when you see an article
and you're like this is just the just
the kind of RI every New York Post
headline that's every headline we get is
like it is begging for engagement yes
it'll be like it'll be just like an
overweight woman in a key and like
quotations I don't care what you say I
look good I'm like G don't look at the
comments don't look at the comments but
the comments are now more fun than the
journalism you know but it wouldn't they
wouldn't keep doing it if it didn't work
it [__] works and they get the
engagement and they get the clicks and
they get the advertisers so it's on us
to just stop but you can't that's the
pickup it's just so difficult to kind of
leave it alone it's like no matter how
many times something says you won't
believe you will not believe
what Tiger Woods his wife looks that I
can't not click on but that's the
problem and like and I will believe but
but I just have it's but sometimes
they're ly sometimes it be like it's all
lies but sometimes it's like a blad and
lie where it'll be like you know she
looks great it'll be like yeah for
sometimes it'll be like Will Smith is
dying and you're like [__] I got to C
he's dying and then you click on you're
like and then you're like oh it was a
fake arle for an orange juice like and
then it's just kind of like
ads yeah man it just but it's how do but
then and then we kind of do it with
Clips as well you had you know you have
to give it spice it up just so like you
know yeah you have to make the the cover
photo say like
Jew where's he going to go with this or
con I had an idea so my mom my mom is
called
ninette oh no yeah exactly so I was like
that could be the most clickbait special
if I had to show entirely about my mom
called nette it's going to suck when she
die you're like nette died we like
woohoo so weird my mom's called bring
the
pain pain with a
Y oh man that's good stuff my mom's
called This n word's
crazy Richard prior album but do you
know what here's another one a topical
peeve please oh I forgot mine just
little drips I keep getting like walking
around New York these just little bits
of I don't know whether it's water or
kind of no one knows what they are
or spit or piss or but it just makes
usually it's in the air conditioner
usually but it's just the most visceral
anger at a city do you know what I mean
it's just one little plop plop and
you're like the [__] and your brain goes
in a million what fluid was there and my
brain is just like is it fentol is it
fentol that's what like the amount mate
I was in LA and I could I was like
pressing you know the traffic lights to
to go across and then I just put my hand
on it and then I was like oh God fent
like and I just became this weird
paranoid British guy that that it's just
everywhere the people are just going
around and just leaving just sharing
everything too every Subway pole is some
guy wiping his ass earlier or a guy who
jerked off and you can't think about it
uh yeah you got a peeve I just [__]
forgot it I'm I'm super jet lags in my
uh I sort of have one I got one too
actually I got let me get a quick one in
here so I'm in
Chicago uh you know over the weekend and
I drink I drink coffee my girlfriend
wants a cappuccino always so I'm at this
the Starbucks downstairs so I have to
now you know when you go to the store
you know but when you go to he knows
what I'm seeing you go to Starbucks they
just hand you the coffee the cappuccino
I know I have to wait and it's a long
line whatever fine with waiting I'm
getting the coffee I wait for a long
time to get the cappuccino for the woman
hands it to me and I I hold it I go well
this is this is light I said I order a
cappuccino she goes yeah that's a
cappuccino very confident that's a
cappuccino two shots of espresso and I
was like well you just said a different
thing you can't tell me that that's yeah
right you just named it a different
thing and I was like that's not a
cappuccino I'm I'm I'm politely like you
know it's not a cappuccino a cappuccino
is just it's just coffee with steamed
milk that's all it is but now some fans
like samarel the diva demands CA even my
car I'm trying to get it for her trying
to be a good guy but then and then she
goes I think she goes I think I know
what a cappuccino is I'm just like you
do Starbuck I I go well you don't and
she goes she goes she goes that's a
cappuccino I go thanks for the Capp I'm
like I'm done I'm not I'm not going to
keep arguing about this so I leave and I
hand it to her and my girlfriend goes
this isn't a cappuccino I'm like thank
you take it
up it just feels like do you know I saw
the other day in a pretam mja I saw this
guy confidently come in and go can I
have a coffee please can I have it extra
hot like they're holding heat back [__]
like what you want a flamethrower you
like can I have it what do you want to
drink it straight from the kettle you
[__] with like extra cuz I'm going to
sue you later but just it was it was the
confidence that's hilarious can be so
sfy just take the LI off and go yeah
yeah hard enough for you yeah is that
hard your skin is falling off it's one
of the is It Something About Mary oh no
no Kingpin that's one of the great bits
of slapstick yeah where he pours the
coffee in the face oh now that's hot
coffee and then that's a great movie you
crazy bastard and the jump out the
window all right what would you P this
one is a little broad it's you guys have
specific you have to call them women
please you got the cappuccino you got
the hot coffee I just I think if someone
has such bad boo that it's ruining the
environment you should be allowed
to hit them with cologne because I
didn't spray them yes okay not hit them
with colog can be unbearable too I'm
thinking more like a like a a body spray
or something okay all right give me some
ax or for
uh the flights the Ubers I'm like you're
ruining the whole trip you're ruining
like you can stink that's fine but now
you're you're it's it's secondhand stink
sure so we're taking it in because you
don't want to shower or wear deodorant
it's not fair to the other people I
pulled a move once on a flight or this
is such a dick move but I wanted to sit
next to my friend and I was sitting next
to the smelliest person ever and my
friend was across like diagonally so I
said oh I'm sorry do you mind switching
with me so I can next to my friend and
the woman goes sure and she moves over
and I just see her turn back when she
smells and look at me and I was just
like what are you going to do though
can't really do anything are you going
to say he's too smelly no you're not
exactly so I won it was a dirty move but
it's a dirty game too yeah it's like the
it's like abortion or whatever your body
your choice but now you're affecting my
life with your stink I on I think if you
I think if you think the person's going
to be a shitty father you should be
allowed to abort their kid too oh I'm
[__] yeah second hand sure but that's I
mean how long are we judging them for
you can't like on a three minutes but if
you seen if you seen them in the waiting
room like I mean do you know what I mean
I talk about that's the ultimate version
of the Larry David
look you just kind of giving it the ice
he carries around body spray carry
around a clothes hanger just in case I'm
with you man it's that thing it's that
he's wearing an Affliction shirt D no
kid get rid of him you know when you see
you hear someone make that
noise oh dude I'm with you but that's
that's another one in terms of like I'm
with
you anything like that where you're like
I I should be allowed to beat you to
death that was a good RFK Junior
impression you but yeah yeah no I'm with
you the lugie hawk guy but just it's
that weird this guy this taxi driver was
doing it from JFK just the whole journey
and you're like it there's it's actually
a uh I think it's called misophonia my
mate's just written a book on it it's
like everyone has certain noises that
just do you know what I mean that make
you want to just Pang them in the face
and maybe you've got it with smells my
girlfriend has it she calls it talking
but yeah yeah sorry no certain people
like there's certain sounds that make me
crazy and uh but apparent that that's it
it's misophonia you'll have like whether
it's just you know like the the classic
one would be the kind of nails on the
chalkboard I feel like everyone hates
that though yeah right yeah exactly I
mean to to the point where if you if you
don't mind that that's a good way of
seeing whether or not somebody should uh
be allowed to be a father I mean if you
could sit for like and you're like I
don't hear anything you're like okay
that wasn't that bad yeah yeah he's
going to raise a killer but you we cut
your peeve off sorry man first time I
ever saw this this week henai porn hanai
porn oh the Asian drawing illustration
porn yeah but it was more of a video you
[__] culta vulture look at you what
is this like when you see like Lois from
Family Guy naked is that what that is no
it's more like uh Asian anime anime
anime porn right and they blurred the
vagina interesting in the animation yeah
that's messed up this guy's trying to
come over here he can't see right wow
but that is maybe it's the guy and who
do you write
to that's the he leaves a comment this
is Despicable just yeah yeah yeah yeah
so just writing into the New York Times
do do you have that do you have the we
have a show in the UK called points of
view where um a TV presenter will read
out the weekly complaints of British
people about TV oh that's fun and it's
mesmerizing but I feel like that's what
you need you don't have Yelp do you we
have Yelp but this is on TV so you have
like kind of Mary from woking was very
upset with this week's episode of
Gardener's world you know just all that
kind of stuff and I feel like that's
what you need yeah well the problem of
those Yelps is you read it and you're
like this is nothing new with the
restaurant you know it'll be a lady like
so I went to the Chinese restaurant to
try it out I mean I was divorced that
day and then I Hade a miscarriage and
then the Russ was very drafty and you're
like how is the food I never ate that
was too sad come on Desperate see if I
can find it so true it's so true they
always go into some spiel about what's
going on in their life instead of
getting to the actual oh I got another
peeve hit me okay people who are this
isn't entirely fair but people who are
really energetic morning people just
pissed me off well this is it but hey
[__] amen and which is every single
DJ DJs in the morning but oh radio DJ me
I thought you that guy every single DJ
in the morning that radio Hi how are you
know the world over so true and yet not
one like you two this is how people
should talk in the morning yes it's just
like how you doing you're right another
day of work it's going tough so much
they're always yelling they have sound
effects yeah yeah isly we're going to do
a funny phone in I did a girl who
basically back flips out of bed and then
she's like you're not a morning person
I'm like no I don't do gymnastics the
second I wake up I don't know what the
[__] you want I mean this is like it
takes me a minute yeah I need like a
glass of water a couple coffees and then
I'm with you take a piss yeah no I'm
with you the morning people are crazy
how about the guy who swims in the
morning you're like what the hell me the
guy the cereal killer out gets up at
6:00 a.m. swims then goes to work oh
it's like someone like Mark wolberg
every so often just kind of shows his
routine yeah it's just like I get up and
I pray for half an hour no you don't
what like nobody wakes up away with some
[__] he might he might pray yeah but and
then it's like a three-hour workout then
it's golf it's just like what are you
thinking man like it's it's so it's
meant my weirdly the only psychopath I
know that can do that is my dad my dad
gets up at I would say half five and
cycles for two hours wow and he's just
like yeah his mom died when he was young
so he has this kind of crazy I'm not
going to die yeah [__] right yeah
full ET man yeah but but it is but it's
that thing of like he's the only stop
showing what you do with the will of the
this is what I wake up to how much work
are you how much work are you giving
this [__] Jesus Christ yeah this
is my phone background look like on the
oh I see right that's now he rides his
bike cut the spokes he puts his dick in
the basket up front woo ET phone home uh
but I know what you mean it's just that
kind of wild morning energy just dumb it
down man like i' they should do that
show just have a morning radio show that
represents how people truly are great
idea I always felt that way they should
do that with workout videos too it's
always a person who's enjoying
themselves give me one slightly out of
shape dude leading the workout class so
so he's not loving it yeah just sat
there going you don't want to be here
neither do I let's go get through this
[__] like that's that's rather than all
the platitudes climb the mountain like
pelaton pelaton are always like I've got
you I've got you no you don't if I if I
if I kill a man you haven't got me how
far does this go exactly like but this
nonsense of like I've got you that would
be great though if he showed up he goes
he comes to court he was like I can
speak to his character wow this guy was
for real I've seen this guy sweat I
would go with the same on porn give me
one porn where it's like you know we
already got stepmom we got interracial
give me hung over cuz that's real a pile
of laundry on your side you're both like
knocking one out until the whole thing
takes 8 seconds hangover porn I agree I
like I think I've Got a Theory on this
the thumbnails the whole video yeah
exactly we we used to have a thing
called reader wives did you have that mm
so basically it was kind of so that was
porn when I grew up in so I was born in
1980 and we'd have like that was the
first like it was was thing called
readers wives and the premise of it was
that people husbands had taking photos
of their wives and this was the first
time you'd see porn and you'd sort of
see like a dog in the background and the
sofa's a bit gnarly the foods no no no
okay but it was it was G but I think
they deliberately looking back on it it
was very scary you know like very angry
s breast thrust at you and kind of like
full walkie like that but my thinking
behind it now is that they were making
porn so scary it was just giving us a
bit more of our childhood you know what
I mean that they were kind of we we need
to make this as Mankey as possible it's
like a Mike Lee film just seeing this
but now you can't get hard unless you
see a pile of dishes in the in the sink
or something I need to see burnt dinner
in the background but and there's always
a cat in them and the cat looks do you
know what I mean it's just sort of sat
there with this like Linda why have you
got your nunar out it's just like this
look of do you know but do you know what
I mean
Linda getting licked yeah but it's it's
it's so it's like a Wes Anderson it's so
like you know so much story to it but
all of it when you see when you're 11 is
like yeah ah it's just it makes you not
want to get married you know like that's
my C at 9 yeah it's it makes you want to
just you know go and play football for a
bit longer do a bit of drawing just stay
in your childhood eat eat some Skittles
you know we had made before we cared
about [__] isn't that amazing that
you one day you didn't care about
[__] and then one day you did yeah
you had your whole life cartoon but then
you stop caring about [__] I mean
once you're in like a longer term
relationship the sex it starts to be
like you almost become like friends yeah
you got to go to a sex club yeah
yeah I still stand by that being a
peculiar move so Mark told me that you
that he' just been to a place called the
kitat club that's it in Berlin and which
is a sex club full of German people now
the German as I said the German accent
is a tough thing to hear not hard but
when they're orgasming that is that is a
cacophony
of sler I mean just say
goodbye like all right you're scaring
him [__] right but can you imagine
you know that or the South Africans I
you know a white a white South South
African man orgasming must be one of the
worst noises you can hear Elon mus does
it a lot he's got 74 kids four he's got
like nine doesn't he I said 74 oh okay
you know you got too many kids when you
got to name one like quo 9000 or
whatever they all have crazy names he's
he's already used up Jeff and Bob and
and
Rudy to numbers got more kids in tweets
it's ridiculous yeah who do you think
you are Nick Canon oh there you go Sho
look oh jeez that's another one what is
it what is it what are people thinking I
don't know they with that photo
or like there's so many things going on
oh those tights were hard to get on that
is an album cover Mark can get out of
those Nick Canon's got 13
kids Point did you wear eyeliner I did
it works he I felt bad like I got curly
hair so it's not really menacing or sexy
so I feel like I had to do something to
my
face it sort of looks that's the thing
you've committed there that's what I
would say do you know what I mean you
could if you're going to go to a leather
club you got to dress the part you just
can't you know you can't slink in
wearing kind of jogging bottom no some
Crocs you got to go all in there's some
big guys at the front door who go they
inspect your outfit and they go I don't
think so oh would you watch people get
turned to work oh yeah there was a line
around the block I mean one lady I
talked to in there she's like oh 4 hours
in line but I'm here like wow if you
shot that in black and white that is an
Oscar winning film just this sad [__]
yeah who's not not kind of leathered up
enough he's going to get back on the
[Music]
bus the opposite of the Holocaust trying
not getting in everyone's laughing at
him and he just sort of see that and the
poor guy just has to go home yeah
goodbye
Jew it's a great Lou bit great Louis bit
what did the girl in the red dress she
was symbolizing something supposedly
America's um overlooking what was going
on there to see but we didn't uh care to
pay attention we yeah it's there for
everyone to late
interesting okay sorry I
asked bummer I thought it was going to
be some cool symbolic thing but that was
uh too
real well let's get this train on the
tracks all right let's get this bun back
in the oven uh okay we lost our gas
what's happening now oh doing Holocaust
bun should we plug dates yeah okay where
you going to be oh yeah I need this [__]
I need this
um uh I'm doing uh yeah a load of East
Coast gigs uh let me get them go see
this guy he's got multiple specials you
you've put the work good you got a show
with your mom got a new show right yeah
it's a new show it's funny it's sort of
I've been there you go oh awesome cheers
dude the 15th of yeah yeah so New York
October that's the one yeah yeah so
we're doing uh yeah that's the UK ones
yeah that's my fault they're all fine
they're all sold out that's fine oh man
that looks now these cats so I'm in
Durham on the 4th yeah Charlotte
Washington I've done the Carolina
Theater that's awesome they're kind of
nice rooms um I'm excited about it just
I just need people wonder the is epic
man you'll get PE people come out it's
um yeah it's it's sort of getting there
but it's so let's go this comes out next
week right so let's get 15 it comes out
on the
15th okay sweet so yeah I'm doing uh St
Louis is that am I doing that right or
St Louis
thanks St Louis Boston Detroit
Indianapolis Cincinnati and Cleveland
and then uh I'm off to Dubai on the 11th
wow yeah that' be fun man and oh you got
hilarities in Cleveland that's one of my
favorite yeah yeah it's sort of that's
the only Comedy Club we're doing uh
annoyingly last time we did quite a few
and they were really we did what's that
amazing Club it's really small it's in
Denver works that's a great gig isn't it
great Club one of the W W's oh I got to
give a wreck uh Michelle wolf if I
watched her special it's great I got to
watch she'll be on here soon she'll be
on here she did like the The Comedy
Works Madison on state Comedy on State
and uh Philly helium I saw her um at
Leicester Square in London a little
while ago and it was pretty much the
same show but sort of doing it over
three sets is kind of interesting as
well it's kind of quite a cool way of
doing it you know cool way to break it
up I I really enjoyed it and you never
get bored because you're like oh now
we're in a new place you know so I kind
of kept it fresh I'll be in uh what is
this the the 15th so this Oklahoma City
Dallas Portland Providence Cleveland
Grand Rapids Denver Denver Grand
Junction Hartford Concord mobile Nola
Santa Rosa Sacramento Omaha you know
where it is Mark Norman comedy.com new
dates added so come on by check it out
get some Bodega cat whiskey and uh buy a
t-shirt for Christ's sake what's peda
cat whiskey that's our whiskey holy
[__] it's up on the bar there the blue
bottle excellent I got uh Pittsburgh
later this month Cleveland uh Columbus
Cincinnati Indianapolis the big one
November 4th uh Theater Madison Square
Garden oh nice please come after that
one buy tickets the theater at MSG and
then I got all over Australia uh Vegas
Florida a bunch of stuff coming up so
sam.com shows hope to see you there have
you gigged in Australia before I never
have oh it's the
best it's really good fun and you're
that's annoying when not at the same
time oh it's it's really great you love
it yeah yeah they're just it's such a
cool cool City yeah have you done it as
well yeah I did it about two months ago
and had a [__] blast yeah Sydney
particularly like Sydney I mean they're
all great but yeah Melbourne too I mean
that
pal water oh I think I'm doing that oh
it's beautiful yeah it's incredible I
don't know what I'm doing but that that
sounds familiar who knows yeah all right
well hey there you go folks so
oh yeah get the pod in there oh yeah if
you want yeah yeah I've got a a new
podcast like I'm like the only person
that didn't have one and now finally
I've got one it's called Wonder box um
and it's just about it's people
essentially talking about things that
they love um it's fun you end up we've
got some good guests John Oliver's on it
yourself nice I'd love you to come on
I'd love to do it yeah yeah we should do
that while I'm around sorry about the
hang over and then yeah don't turn up
like he turned up with shades on in
[__] England well I love booze so it
was part of the Wonder box um yeah yeah
you did you I mean I think the first
thing you put in was uh um a gag ball
yeah cuz of the sex club yeah and most
people put like you know like a a pet or
a loved one wow but that's what it was
It's oddly it's a really cool way of uh
of sort of having a chat with people
because rather than Comics coming up and
doing bits it puts them into a different
space and also there's kind of a bravery
about talking about things you like do
you know what I mean it's kind of quite
easy to sort of great
things you like the things you like like
you talking about film you clearly don't
you what I mean you sort of Lose
Yourself a bit rather than than nagging
and and pulling stuff apart yeah man
taking the piss out of as you would say
there you go hello I'm trying all right
well there you go check out Wonder box
check out Russell on the road and uh
check us out we got specials also if you
want to go back and look at the old
stuff we'll see you in hell thank you
Sunday's day for
[Music]
my the be CL
I've had a little too B and Norman's
talking sh [__] and I get down the
same Up on the Roof like a cop coming
and naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember and I get down in the same
way he's
might
the
true